[Music]
you smell terrible
you stink hair starts growing in weird
places and red sores break out across
your face no you're not turning into a
werewolf
you're not even on death's doorstep
it's just puberty and every human has to
go through it
usually this process takes years and it
still stinks but
what if all these changes happen to you
in just one day
if your body grew this fast could your
mind keep up with it
how would super fast puberty affect your
relationships
and could all these quick changes drive
you a little insane
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you went through puberty in 24 hours
puberty is an emotional roller coaster
but with all the extreme physical
changes that happen you could say it's a
roller coaster
it's one of the most dramatic and
traumatic processes that humans
experience
but it would start off very quietly
imagine you're nine years old sleeping
in your pajamas
but deep inside your brain a ticking
time bomb would be about to go off
your pituitary gland
it's only the size of a pea but it's
called the master gland because it
controls the production and release of
most body altering hormones
boom your pituitary exploded into
hyperactivity
it would start spewing out hormones that
would set off a chain reaction and it
would trigger other glands to produce
even more hormones at incredible speeds
in girls the ovaries would start
producing estrogen and in boys the
testicles would produce testosterone
these two hormone monsters would cause
the horror show you're about to
experience
when you woke up you'd be around 11
years old and your body would already be
very different
right away you'd notice some changes
downstairs
okay by 9 am you'd be around 13 years
old and it's time to go to school
get ready because you'd be about to
undergo rapid extreme changes in front
of your whole class
hair would start growing on your legs
your arms and armpits and
down there too
and what are those ugly spots
acne would start spreading on your face
and back
your private parts would get bigger too
and to make matters worse your voice
would start to crack and i'm not happy
unless you're a girl girls voices don't
go all weird oh my god i'm going to
puberty
by 11 am you would experience a massive
growth spurt adding up to seven
centimeters to your height every 90
minutes
your muscle mass would increase too
finally
but your motor control would be almost
impossible
it could have something to do with the
constant pain fatigue and hunger from
growing so fast
oh and i hope you brought bigger clothes
because when lunch is over your first
outfit won't fit you anymore
yeah and you'd want some deodorant too
because now you'd be producing some
seriously funky body odor
by 1pm you'd have the body of a 14 year
old so the worst is over right
wrong it would seem like this nightmare
will never end
inside your body those fast acting
hormones would be creating an emotional
rollercoaster
this sped up growth would make you feel
like you're going crazy from the wide
range of emotions you're experiencing
and that could be hard on your
friendships
you might be sobbing one second and
laughing hysterically the next
staying focused would become next to
impossible
and sometimes you would get overly
excited
then the girls would start getting their
first period
and then the next one and one more every
seven and a half minutes
[Applause]
their reproductive organs would work so
fast that it would cause extreme
discomfort and pain
for the boys their voice would get
much deeper probably my best year of
school ever and is that a little peach
fuzz i see
okay your body would be transforming so
fast that it would consume all your
energy
you'd be exhausted and feel sleepy
and on top of that you'd experience
sudden outbursts of anger
you'd be a real pain to deal with
puberty is a neurological firestorm
add to that the social pressures of
adolescence and it can lead to serious
mental health problems
by 6 pm your body would be like a 15
year old's
you'd make it home for dinner gloomy and
sullen
what a day
you'd be starving from your extreme
growth spurt so you would need to
consume 10 to 15 percent more calories
than your parents just to break even
and as you went to bed your body would
be around age 16
you'd feel exhausted frightened and in
pain
but your growth would start to slow down
and right before you turn off the light
you could see in the mirror a hopeful
glimmer of what lies
ahead the wispy beginnings of a beard
in just one day you'd grow an average of
30 centimeters and even though i said
you weren't turning into a werewolf
thick coarse hair in all the funny
places
would now reach its full potential
welcome to adulthood
hey adolescence is no joke but imagine
that you didn't stop growing
what if you grew to five meters tall
well you already know that that's a
story
or another
what if